Thank you, and welcome to Detroit.
Has anyone told you
how we greet each other here yet?
“What up doe?”
Not "what up, dog?"
“What up doe.”
(Laughter)
Very well.
In Detroit, in 2021,
we experienced a 100-year flood.
A rain event dumped
seven inches of rain on Detroit.
Cars were stranded on highways,
people were literally swimming
and kayaking down residential streets.
Homes, businesses, infrastructure
were inundated with heavy rainfall,
resulting in over a billion dollars
in flood damages.
It was unlike anything we had seen before.
Wait a minute, that's not true.
Because, in 2014 ...
Detroit had a 100-year flood.
Four to six inches of rain
were dumped on Detroit.
Cars were stranded on highways,
people were literally swimming
and kayaking down residential streets.
Homes, businesses and infrastructure
were inundated with heavy rainfall
and sustained over a billion dollars
in flood damages.
Now I'm no mathematician,
but 2014 to 2021 is not 100 years.
(Laughter)
I am a public health social worker,
and what that means is I focus
on developing interventions
that help to improve
the health and well-being
of individuals and communities.
In particular, I'm concerned
with preventing harm.
I think there are ways
that we can learn from the past
in order to apply some lessons
so that we do better when preparing
for near-future
and distant-future climate crises.
So let's start by thinking about the past.
My grandparents were born and raised
in a small town in the southern US,
Boligee, Alabama.
They decided,
like many families in the '50s,
to leave the South and to move north,
to pursue a better life.
In particular, my grandfather
wanted to leave the agricultural industry
and find work in the automotive industry.
So my grandparents,
Martha and Booker O'Neil,
packed up their four children,
their hopes and dreams,
their practices and prayers,
their tried-and-true traditions,
and headed north.
Boligee was a small farming town
with about nine surnames,
about 150 residents,
and the cows outnumbered the people.
It was very different than Detroit.
Detroit was wildly different.
At the time, it was
the fifth-largest city in the US,
so it had a little
over a million residents,
busy streets, an active nightlife.
What they experienced when they came here
could be considered,
in some senses of the word,
climate change.
I know that's different
than how we usually think
about climate change,
but stay with me,
I'll make sense of it as we go.
When families moved here from the South,
they experienced weather in ways
that they never experienced it before,
a lot like what we're experiencing
right now, across the globe, right?
They had to contend with snow in Detroit
and very short and mild summers
that really didn't compare to the summer
heat that they were used to.
There are two definitions of climate.
The first is the one
that we all expect to talk about
during this summit:
"Climate: the general weather conditions
usually found in a particular place."
And then, there's another
definition of climate
that we'll get to later,
and talk about how that
affects climate change.
For the first time ever,
families that arrived here from the South
were experiencing this new climate.
And they had to have strategies
in order to adjust to the new climate.
They used three key strategies --
acceptance, aid and adaptation.
So first, acceptance.
They had to acknowledge
that they would not experience the weather
the same way they had in the past.
They had to recognize that they could not
deny, avoid or alter it.
As we do a better job of accepting
that this is our new climate,
then we could do a better job of planning,
preparing, responding and recovering.
We have to realize that climate change
is not a distal threat.
It is at our front doors,
or in the case of Detroit
during the floods,
in our basements.
The second strategy they used was aid.
When folks arrived here in the city,
they set up communities,
communities of mutual aid,
where they helped
and supported each other.
They helped each other find housing,
and jobs and land to grow food.
In part, our ability
to adjust to climate change
is reliant upon our willingness
to support each other.
In 2014 and 2021,
when there were floods in Detroit,
residents responded.
Neighbors, congregations,
friends responded,
when government was not nimble enough
to respond to the critical needs
of community members.
The third way that they survived
this new climate was adaptation.
They had to recognize
that it was important to invest
in the tools that they would need
in order to adapt to this new climate.
They had to get shovels.
They had to have sand and salt
to deal with icy conditions,
they had to cover
their windows with plastic
to keep the cold winds from coming in.
We must take action to adapt
for our current and near-future
climate change,
and it will take us all --
community members,
community organizations,
business, industry, local government
must come up with plans,
and then put those plans into action.
In the '50s, many who migrated north
thought that they would escape
Jim Crow laws.
What they found is a new form
of racism in the North.
Bigotry, racism and discrimination
limited their access to healthy housing,
the best neighborhoods, the best jobs,
political power, et cetera.
In the '20s,
the 2020s ...
bigotry, racism, discrimination
limit access to healthy housing,
the best neighborhoods,
political power --
you know where I'm going with this.
It is important, then,
that we pay attention
to the second definition of climate,
and that has to do
with the social conditions
and political conditions
and feelings and opinions
that get in the way of us making
progress on climate change
and in other areas that we're trying
to make progress in.
So the three strategies
are acceptance, aid and adaptation.
When we're looking at climate change,
we also have to be mindful
of how social and political conditions
can stifle progress
and get in the way of our progress
toward preparing and planning
for climate change.
Being thoughtful about how we apply
these three key strategies
that worked in the past
to our present circumstances,
while remembering
to center community voices
and experience and honor community assets
is our best bet at success.
In 2014, it rained,
and we were surprised and not prepared.
In 2021,
we weren't that surprised,
but still ill-prepared.
It's going to rain again, no surprise.
We have to make sure
that we're prepared.
We can be prepared
for the next climate-related crisis,
by accepting that climate change
is our current reality,
creating and supporting formal
and informal systems of mutual aid,
and adapting our thinking
and our actions to prepare
for current and future crises.
Thank you.
(Applause)